بالمئه من المستهلكين لم يعرفوا تكاليف
نفقاتهم الشهريه الا عندما توقفوا عن
استخدام البطاقه الائتمانيه نتائج دراسه
حديثه نشرها موقع وملخصها ان الناس تميل
عاده الى الانفاق اكثر عند استخدام
البطاقات الائتمانيه لا يقتصر الامر على
احتماليه كبيره لشراء شيء ما بسعر اعلى بل
من المرجح ان نكون اكثر عرضه للشراء
الاندفاع ايضا وعلى قدر اهميه بطاقات
الائتمان الا انها تفتك بميزانيات الاسر
سامع عادل اذا فشلت تحكم فيها وديونها
تسبب ازمه طويله الامد لملايين الاسر حول
العالم في حال التاخر عن مواعيد السداد
الشهريه في الجانب الاقتصادي ايضا نتساءل
سؤال منطقي هل نحتاج فعلا الى البطاقه
الائتمانيه ولا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنا الان مشاهدينا الصحفيه في قسم
الاقتصاد سمر الموسطه اهلا بك يا صباح
الخير وين بطاقتي
على التلفون على التليفون هسه دفعت في زمن
الدفع الالكتروني وزمن كاشلس ورود اللي هو
زمن بدون كاش اللي احنا عملناه
صحيح هل يمكن انه نتخلى عن او ما يكون في
عنا بطاقه ائمانيه شوفي ايش سويت سويت
دراسه بسيطه سالت كم احد ويانا اذا عندك
عائله وعندك اقساط مدارس وعندك اسم الله
ضروري يعني ما تعرفين يصير حادث يصير شيء
صعب التخلي عن يكاد يكون مستحيل تخليه
واذا عايشه على الراتب 80% من الاشخاص
يعيشون من الراتب الى الراتب معتمدين 100%
على الراتب لا يوجد مصدر اخر 80% من
الاشخاص حول العالم هذا طبعا من العاملين
يعني في اشخاص لا يعملون
صعب اذا كنت كعائله كشخص سنجل جدا من
السهل التخلي عن البطاقه الائتمانيه وهو
امر يعني طبعا ينصح به الخبراء التوفير
شيء مهم جدا احب اقول اليوم انه احنا
يوميا تقريبا بين يوم ويوم خلينا من يجيني
اوفر من بنك ينطيني بطاقه ائتمانيه بس نحط
ببالنا هذا البنك مدى يتصل للسواد عيوننا
هذا البنك اكيد عنده اعتفادة يريد يسوي
فلوس فهو يعني خلو هايا في في ذهنكم هو
هذا البنك لا يتصل لسواد عيونك هو اكيد
هناك الى مصلحه بهذا الموضوع فلا ننقاد
حول الاوفرز العديده اللي تجينا من عده
بنوك ايضا لما احنا لما يكون عندنا اكثر
من بطاقه ائتمانيه بنفس الوقت او اكثر من
بطاقتين تحديدا هوايه ناس يقومون بذلك
لانه تجيهم اوفر هذا ينطيك ديس كانت هذا
يعطيك كاش باك هذا يعطيك اير مايلز هذول
اكثر مو بس بيصرف اكثر هذا في شيء عندك
اسمك يعني اذا انت كنت هسا ده تسوين بطاقه
ائتمانيه او هسه داخله على سوق الائتمان
لما يشوف عندك كثير بطاقات ائتمانيه
الكريدت سكور المحصله تنزل فبالنهايه
بعدين لما صدق تحتاجين بطاقه ائتمانيه صعب
ينطوك قسط او لون
بعدين في المراحل المقبله يعني اليوم
البطاقه الائتمانيه اكيد كما تقولين ليس
لسواد عيوننا هم ياخذون نسبه بتخصم هذه
النسبه الى اخره البعض يتغلب عليها
بالسداد الفوري انه تخصم من البطاقه يحول
هذا المبلغ وبالتالي يقول اني انا
بالمنطقه الامنه لكن اذا تراكمت ودخلنا في
موضوع فوائدها كيف يمكن ان يتعامل هي هاي
المشكله انه ايضا من
المساوا يكون عندك اكثر من بطاقه ائتمانيه
لانه ما حد تقدر تكون مرتب واورجنايس
الخبراء انه انت كل يوم مثلا اذا عطلتك
جمعه وسبت سبت واحد كل يوم عطله الصبح
بتقعد تقضي لك ساعه تنظم الامور والبايمنز
والدفعات الى اخره لانه مثلا الان تقول لي
زميلك كنا نتحدث انه شنو موضوع الحلقه
قالت لي انا كان علي مبلغ معين لنفترض
عشره الاف
ريال او درهم لنفترض او دولار دفعت منه
تسعه الاف وخمسميه باقي 500 نسيتها لانه
دفعت كاش بالهايا 500 ناسيه بتحطها او ما
انتبهت يعني بعدين دفعت عليها غرامه على
هاي ال500 800 عرفتي لانه هي فائده
متراكمه يعني هي فائده انت ماخذه الف سنين
بالميه عليك انت بس بعدين الف ومئه الف
و20 او الف ومحسن
كنت حابه اساله يقال بانه
الفائده وابدا اقول الفائده على البطاقه
الائتمانيه دائما تكون اعلى بكثير من
الفائده على القرض الشخصي هل اذا تراكمت
عنا يعني لازم 30% اكثر يعني البطاقه
الائتمانيه هل الافضل انه ناخذ قرض شخصي
لسداده خصوصا على المبالغ الكبيره يعني
على المشتريات الصغيره
واذا انت عارفه نفسك انه انت انسانه منظمه
وحتخلين وقت معين ترتبين بها دفعاتك بس
دفعات كبيره مثل اقساط سياره مثلا اقساط
المدرسه الى اخره القروض تكون افضل
والاسوء سحب الكاش سحب الكاش الفائده ممكن
توصل على الكريدت كارد حاولوا ما تسحبوا
ما المشكله ايضا اللي اللي ما يقدر يستغني
عن البطاقه اليوم
اللي هو الفور الحساب
البنك الجاري ما نقدر نستخدمه بكل شيء
احيانا
في الخارج مثلا او توقف او انت بحاجه الى
بطاقه مسانده في السفر فبالتالي بحاجه الى
بطاقه ائتمانيه اليوم هل نستطيع ان نستغني
عنها بنوك الكترونيه
اكيد لا لانه كمان الصراحه انا اشوفها
اامن من تستعملينه عليها
مثلا او تشتري برا في الخارج اامن تستخدم
الكريدت كارد لانه عليها مثلا 8000 او
10,000
ما راح يقدر يسحب هوايه فمن هذه الناحيه
فهي بالتاكيد اامل بس بالتاكيد نحاول
نتجنبها اذا نستطيع شكرا جزيلا
صحفيه في قسم الاقتصاد وعلى هذه النصائح
والمعلومات كم بطاقه ثمانيه عندك اثنين
شكرا
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات